in this video i'm going to be breaking
down episode 9 of attack on titan season
4 in which aaron completed his
transformation from a one-legged hobo
into an instagram model there's a lot to
explain about this episode because a
large portion of it was a flashback to
three years ago
so i'll be talking about how all those
scenes link into the present day of the
series
additionally this video will cover other
things that i thought were interesting
such as why zeke and aaron have now been
separated
the return of annie and why jolina stole
the titan transformation serum from mali
let me know your thoughts on the episode
in the comments down below and be sure
to stick around till the end as that's
when i'll be giving my personal rating
out of 10.
okay so episode 9 was called brave
volunteers and it begins with armin back
on parodies island after they escaped
from mali in the last episode
we can see he's holding a conch in his
hands which was a prized possession that
he acquired during their first visit to
the sea
in the final episode of season three
that trip to the beach occurred in the
year 851
and later that same year is when the
flashbacks in this episode occurred
present-day armin reminisces about the
first time mali sent their survey ships
to the island
and thanks to peak's words in the last
episode we already know that elena was
part of that expedition
when the flashback starts one of the
malian ships had already landed on the
shore
but they hadn't been heard from for a
while so the other ship begins to
approach
as they progress they are ambushed by
the attack titan who appears out of the
water and lifts this thing with his bare
hands
this scene is a parallel to when aaron
kruger revealed his identity as the
attack titan
as he also lifted a marlin ship on his
back before breaking it in half
admittedly though aaron is probably
carrying a heavier ship by the looks of
it
so i'll allow him for not snapping it
like kruger did back then
hanji was ecstatically waiting to greet
the malian soldiers and i'll explain why
the scouts were already prepared for
mali to arrive
to put it simply after the events of
last season everyone and parodies became
aware
that the world considered them to be an
enemy they knew that at some point in
the near future
marley would attempt to invade once
again because the island is seen as an
existential threat to humanity as a
result they set up this camp near the
ocean
with armin and aaron serving as the
defense against enemy invaders
when mali finally arrived hanji's goal
was to learn as much as possible about
the outside world
which is information that only foreign
soldiers would know back then armin was
of a similar mindset to hanji
as he saw an opportunity to gather
information as well and later believing
that they could become friends if
everyone got to know each other
yeah that didn't work out too well in
the end anyway hanji greets the malian
soldiers
but next to her is another soldier from
the first survey ship that went missing
two hours earlier
this guy's name was nikolo and yeah they
were kind of threatening him with a
sword behind his back
in an attempt to kind of like get the
other marlin soldiers to cooperate
the idea was that nicola would play
along with hanji's routine but
as you can see even with the threat of
death he still you know he still wasn't
really up for it
nicolo's hatred for aldians is so
ingrained that he literally wanted the
captain to start firing
even though he himself would likely have
been killed in the process
looking at this opening scene it made it
all the more interesting to see later in
the episode when nicolo was mourning for
an eldian but we'll get to that later
as the malian captain prepared to fire
he was surprisingly assassinated on the
spot by elena before she and her
comrades turned their guns on their
fellow malian soldiers
peak revealed in the last episode that
elena was a follower of zeke
and here we find out exactly what that
means within the malian military there
are countless soldiers who are not
actually malians
but rather they are from nations that
marley has conquered both elena and
onyankapon are examples of these
non-malian soldiers and as a result they
have no real loyalty or allegiance to
the country
when the first survey fleet left for
parodies island zeke had already told
elaine
to shoot her commanding officer if
necessary and to tell the leaders on
parodies what he's seeking to gain
however before we get into what zeke
wants there's a couple of things i
should point out during this flashback
number one is that aaron began to show
his first signs of discontent in this
scene
when he points out that parodies need to
do something to protect themselves
while armin seemed optimistic about the
future aaron was concerned that mali's
military could destroy them in a real
battle
and he reiterates that point later in
the episode insisting that parodies need
something to stop other countries from
attacking them the second thing to point
out is that during elena's initial
meeting with hanji and levi
she foreshadows several things that
we've already seen in the final season
for example she mentions how mali can't
currently invade paradise because
they're at war with an alliance of other
nations
the war that she's referring to is
literally what this season began with
but as an audience we only got to see
the end of it
she also introduces them to new
technologies such as the semi-automatic
pistols
which is now standard equipment for
these soldiers on parodies
another thing was when onyankapon tried
to explain the concept of aerial weapons
much to hanji's amazement and many years
later he would be the one trusted to fly
the airship
during the battle in mali moving on now
elena revealed three years ago that
zeke's true goal
is to free the eldium people but he had
two requests that needed to be fulfilled
before he could achieve that
zeke's first request was that he'd be
accepted onto parody's island
and his second request was that he'd be
introduced to the founding titan
aka eren yeager at this point in the
timeline
aaron and zeke are seemingly the only
people who know how to use the full
power of the founding titan
naturally a lot of people had seen aaron
use the founding titan before
but he never actually told anyone how he
was able to do it in this episode he
finally reveals his secret and says he
only concealed the truth to protect
historia
as obviously you know if he told
everyone then it's possible she may have
been turned into a titan like dinah
fritz
with the full power of the founding
titan parodies would be able to activate
the rumbling and defend themselves that
way
but at this point in the story we still
don't know the full details of zeke's
secret plan
in this exact same scene in the manga
zeke said that if his demands were met
he would guarantee the island's safety
provide them with the latest weapons
give them intelligence that would hurt
mali and act as a middleman between
parodies island
and potential friendly nations around
the world it seems like a pretty good
deal to get all of that
just for bringing the guy to the island
and then introducing him to eren
but naturally a lot of people were
against the idea of you know trusting
this guy after he killed
most of the survey corps despite her
reservations hanji did decide that it
was practical to work with the malian
volunteers
and thanks to the help of elena and
onyankapon paradise was able to
neutralize
30 more malian ships over the next three
years
we know this because present day zeke
already revealed that 32 ships in total
had gone missing
just before we continue be sure to smash
the like and sub buttons if you want to
see more attack on titan breakdowns like
this
anyhow onyankapon and a few other
volunteers helped to modernize the
island
by proposing the plans to construct a
port a port would enable parodies to
potentially trade with other nations in
the future
using the same ships that they captured
from mali this scene was kind of funny
because it showed us just how out of the
loop the people and parodies really are
after 100 years of knowing nothing about
the outside world i say this because
sasha asks onyankapon why his skin is
dark
because yeah i mean if you think about
it there have been no black people on
the island that we've been aware of
so it does make sense that she would ask
this question it was a combination of
curiosity and ignorance
but onyankapon smoothly answers by
telling her that whoever created
humanity
thought it would be interesting to have
different kinds of people in the world
as a side note regarding the port itself
we've previously seen that paris island
already does have a small port that was
constructed decades ago
although that must have been on another
part of the island that port was made by
mali specifically so that they could
turn aldians into
titans so it doesn't exactly have the
best history but you know it's still
there
the episode then progressed to an
interesting moment involving nicolo
which partly proves armin's belief that
malia's and eldens can understand each
other
nicola was the captive marlin soldier
that was threatened by levi in the
beginning
and here we find out that he is also a
chef he was forced to prepare a feast of
seafood
which sasha mercilessly tears into even
to the point where she's crying real
tears
until this point the chef had only shown
a hatred for aldians
but once he saw her enjoyment at his
cooking that hatred began to crack just
a little bit
during these times armin really thought
they could change something
as many mallions were able to overcome
their prejudices against aldians
when given sufficient time to do so he
believed that threatening the world with
the rumbling was not something they had
to do
if they could just talk to other nations
once the port was completed however
being the pragmatist that he is
aaron wasn't really buying armin's
optimism as most of the malians who
arrived on the island
still hated the aldean race aaron knew
that the world's perceptions of aldians
is hard to change
because whether they're good people or
not aliens at the end of the day
they're still human beings that can turn
into these man-eating monsters
getting the world to accept that after
nearly 2 000 years of titan domination
was a pretty unrealistic goal on top of
all of that
zeke only had a few years left to live
at this point so
the you know if they were going to bring
him to paris island then that is also on
a time limit
that's why three years later aaron would
eventually grow frustrated
and begin his own plan to infiltrate
marley and get his brother back to the
island
i thought this part was done really well
when aaron was firing at the shooting
range
only for the scene to transition into
sasha getting hit by a bullet
this was meant to symbolize that sasha's
death was eren's fault
which is something that i think we've
pretty much all accepted at this point
present day armin continues to talk to
someone off screen and wonders if there
was a different more peaceful path they
could have taken
the anime then gives us a small preview
of instagram model aaron before moving
over to mikasa at the cemetery
nicolo had arrived to find out if sasha
really died but was being physically
abused by a random aldean
because niccolo is a marlin volunteer
this is quite an ironic thing to happen
considering the way the aliens
themselves are treated across the world
but it's yet another example that
eldians on parodies can sometimes be no
better
than the people who oppress them after
spending the past three years on the
island
nicolo had affection towards sasha and
appreciated her love for his food
unlike the version of himself that hated
aliens in the beginning you can tell
that he was truly devastated by this
loss
sasha's parents then show up as well as
this girl who is the one that sasha
saved from a titan after her village was
destroyed
this was back in season 2 when the
citizens of connie's village were turned
into titans
and sasha's heroics that day are the
only reason this girl is still alive
moving on aaron and zeke were
immediately separated once they arrived
on the island
as they can't yet be trusted to use the
power of the founding titan
on the airship these two were prevented
from making contact as aaron had his
arms restrained
and zeke couldn't really do anything
because his limbs were chopped off by
levi
now that they're back on parodies zeke
was put under levi's supervision
and transported to this massive forest
full of trees we saw before how the draw
titan is the only one that's really able
to take advantage of this environment
and when it comes to the beast titan
there's really not much he can do
there are no rocks around not to mention
that there's a ton of space for the
scouts to maneuver with their odm gear
zeke is being kept here until they
decide what they're gonna do with him
but in the meantime he does seem to show
some concern for gabby and falco
those two had already been locked up in
prison since arriving on the island so
not much to say regarding that
other than that gabby is clearly
organizing her one-person kill list in
her head
the next thing i need to explain relates
to the anti-malian volunteers as it's
been no secret since the beginning that
they were working for zeke the whole
time
with the man himself now arriving on the
island commander pixis decides to have
these guys restrained
so that they can't make an effort to
communicate with him luckily for them
elena doesn't take it too personally
and the titan transformation serum that
you see on the table was stolen by her
from mali
you may be wondering why powdy's island
would even need such a thing
and the simple answer is that they may
need this serum in the future
so that when it's time to eat aaron or
to eat zeke they'll be able to create
pure titans capable of doing so
i'm not saying they're going to eat
aaron or zeke right now but you know
eventually one day
they're gonna need to eat them before
the curse of emir kills them so you know
it's
necessary for the future of the island
in a dimly lit room armin continues to
talk with someone off screen
as he continues speaking the camera pans
to reveal the person he's been talking
to this whole episode was none other
than annie leonhardt
aka the female titan annie is still
encased inside this crystal after four
years
and is seemingly in an unconscious state
it's a good thing she doesn't need to
eat or drink whilst inside this thing
otherwise she would have died a long
time ago at first glance it might appear
strange that armin is taking time to you
know
speak to the unconscious body of someone
who betrayed them all
but there is actually a couple of good
reasons why he would do this
firstly armin succeeded bertolt is the
colossal titan
and whilst he might not be able to see
berto's memories it's possible that
bertott's feelings may be influencing
armin instead
we know that armin's predecessor had a
long-standing crush on annie
so it's possible that you know that
crush is the reason armin is drawn to
talk to her
additionally armin feels guilty for what
the scouts did in mali
and annie is a great person to talk to
this about as she basically did the same
thing just to parodies instead
the episode ends with mikasa still in
the cemetery and she repeats the phrase
that eren once said to her when they
were kids
back then eren saved her life by killing
two human traffickers that were planning
to sell her
but the third kidnapper managed to grab
him by the neck in this moment he told
mikasa to fight
because if they don't fight then they
can't win and if they don't win then
they're gonna die
eren's words help mikasa to activate her
ackman powers
turning her into the super soldier that
she is today in my opinion
the reason mikasa repeats this phrase at
this moment is to reassure herself that
sasha didn't die in vain
and that the fight against mali was
necessary to ensure their survival
at the same time aaron fixes his hair
into a not so stylish man-bun
and tells his reflection to fight almost
like he's trying to psych himself
up for something that's yet to come with
that said that was my breakdown of
episode 9 of attack on titan season 4.
this was a really solid episode and i
kind of appreciated the way they
rearranged certain things when compared
to the manga
to me the flashbacks were a lot less
confusing than they might have been so
yeah they really did a good job in
the pacing and also the organization of
the flashbacks
overall this episode gets an 8 out of
10. as usual i'd appreciate if you
dropped a like on this video
and share it with any attack on titan
fans who you think might not understand
what happened in this episode
thanks for watching as always and until
the next one peace out